Theodore and clear we're each asked to
factor the term 24x to the fifth as the
product of two monomials their responses
are shown below
so Theodore factored 24x to the fifth as
being equal to 8x third times three x
squared and Claire factor 24x to the
fifth is being equal to four x times 6x
to the fourth and then they ask us which
of the students factored 24 X to the
fifth correctly so I encourage you pause
the video and see if you can figure out
figure this out which of them factored
it correctly
alright now let's first look at Theodore
so he factored it into these two
monomials 8 X to the third + 3 x squared
well let's just see if we were to
multiply these two things do we get 24 X
to the fifth so if you multiply 8 times
3 you do indeed get 24 and then all you
have to do is multiply the X terms or
the the X to the powers of X you have X
to the 3rd times x squared that indeed
does equal X to the 5th
so Theodore did factor it correctly this
is one factorization I guess you'd say
of 24 X to the 5th now let's look at
Claire so Claire if we were to take just
the coefficients 4 times 6 is indeed
equal to 24 and then if we were to look
at the powers of X we have X to the
first power here times X to the fourth
power which is going to be X to the
fifth power so Claire also factored it
correctly and this just goes to show you
that there's more than one possible
factorization of a monomial like 24 X to
the fifth I could come up with another
one I could write something like 24 X to
the fifth I could say that that is 12x I
could write that as 12 X to the third
times let's see what would have to be
left 12 times 2 is 24 so 2x squared
that's another possible factorization so
clearly there's just more more than one
way to factor this monomial into two
other monomials